[Applaudissements]
s'intéresser à des nouveaux génies qui
viennent d'arriver puisque je vous le
dis la villa des coeurs brisés vient
d'arriver et là encore il se passe des
choses alors on va vous rappeler le
pitch de l'émission d'anciens candidats
de télé réalité à la recherche de l'âme
soeur se retrouve dans une luxueuse
villa où leur sont régulièrement
proposés des célibataires anonyme dans
leur quête amoureuse
ils reçoivent les conseils de lucie une
love coach alors vous mettez qu'un
célibataire dans une villa dont vous
attendez une journée un peu de soleil un
peu de cocktails et hop tout le monde
couche avec tout le monde un petit peu
le délire donc à leur premier jour de
l'émission
la love coach est chargé de faire le
poids pour établir les règles du jeu il
vérifier si tout le monde et bien
célibataire
tout se passe bien jusqu'à ce que ça
tombe sur le gars qui s'appelle simo
alors on sent que le mec est célibataire
mais pas de ouf comme ennemi web sans
regarder nous a fais moi team kenwood
date alors fait trois cent vingt deux
jours chez célibataire je suis
célibataire depuis 141 jours
moi ça fait cent soixante quinze jours
que je suis célibataire ça fait deux
cent soixante et un jour je suis batteur
depuis 307 jours depuis combien de temps
est-ce que tu es célibataire je ne suis
pas célibataire au jour d'aujourd'hui
pour moi dans ma tête je suis
célibataire
cette personne manière concise clair
clair moi je ne suis plus avec elle
est-ce que tu m'a dit je te quitte
je n'arrive pas à faire ça parce que
pour moi c'est donc tu es en couple je
ne suis pas un courtier qui a envie de
rompre mais tu es en course je ne sais
pas je ne j'ai envie de rentrer en
vigueur en suisse en cours j'en fais
encore plus je suis en couple au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec une personne qui
pense que je suis en vacances
[Applaudissements]
voilà et pitt
tu sais pas ce qu'il répète mais c'est
juste qu'il a pas de coups bas la
courage voilà vous dit juste qu'il n'a
pas de ça veut rien dire soit voilà c
est ce compliqué et il vous est avec
vous n'êtes pas avec ce conflit cated
moi je défendrai toujours le guetter un
saut prix mais là c'est compliqué face à
face variées vous faire la vire sa meuf
pendant la saison et c'est ça va faire à
des rebondissements on en fait il avait
sa meuf mais s'est dit bon je préfère le
buzz quoi qualité
tu penses map alors pour pimenter
l'émission la production a fait revenir
dans la villa les ex de certains
contrats notamment julie l'ex petit ami
d'antoine je sais pas du tout qui sont
ces gens elle vient demander des
explications sur des sextos quand douad
qu'antoine a envoyé à sa meilleure amie
des sextos c'est des sms un peu choquant
voilà un terreau codes du genre ça va
alors que fait un gars quand il est pris
en flagrant délit mammeri évidemment il
y la règle d'or en crions pas où l'air
toujours nier en criant car ça c'est pas
mon zizi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été drogué
[Musique]
donc ça le problème c'est qu'antoine
apparemment il a pas tellement
l'habitude des interrogateurs du fbi
et voici le mytho qui craquent le plus
vite
comment regarder même série que toi
conception du collège on note vraiment
quel nom ce n'est pas parce que moi sur
mon tabouret semaine on a eu quand je
sais que s'envoient des messages en
interne hier en disant j'ai envie d'être
maquillée des trucs comme ça tu sors ça
d'où toi non
non il n'y a pas de problème jusqu'à
envoyer des messages en temps j'ai envie
de se moquer j'aurais vraiment ac
c'était ça le message
j'étais vraiment voyez ça ok alors
j'oubliais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyez ça j'aime alors j'ai oublié je
voulais la vérité le pire exceptionnel
quoi c'est un bail que j'aurais pu dire
ça mais oui j'ai oublié je vois pas ce
que moi j'oublie les choses ma maison je
veux dire c'est vrai j'en voulais
bailian oubliée des trucs alors dans la
villa des coeurs brisés ya vincent
vincent le connais bien c'est un pro de
la télé réalité
il a fait toutes les émissions dix fois
j'adore et le mec il a toujours la même
balle annihile peut pas s'empêcher de
regarder le popotin des phillies ont mis
popotin sur ma fiche 1 et quand il se
fait griller il sort le meilleur
argument du monde
vraiment vincent chapeau voilà bravo
o'keefe
oui tony trop chine c'est ton vrai
prénom oui
non je regardais juste comment ça
s'écrit le mytho mytf1 parce que dans le
ciel de m'avoir merci